as last month's Sudan crisis mounted the
Royal Air Force's transport Fleet
mobilized
here a C-130 Hercules loads up Marines
to help with evacuations
the aircraft can also be used by Special
Forces
but it's being retired next month to cut
costs even as security threats grow
this is where the c-130s are based
alongside a replacement Fleet of newer
larger and more capable aircraft called
the atlas a400m
still the local MP is worried they're a
niche C-130 capabilities that still need
to be transferred onto a400 a400 has
serviceability and reliability
availability concerns and even leaving
that aside even if that weren't the case
there are fewer airframes now than there
would have been before the urgent need
to evacuate British Nationals from Sudan
saw c-130s and a400s flying back and
forth from an air base in Cyprus the Sky
News data and forensics unit identified
three c-130s involved in the mission
they made 1930s and evacuated more than
700 people four a400 seem to have taken
part flying 22 trips and evacuating more
than 1700 people internal documents also
reveal that as of the 5th of may just
one out of seven of the C-130 fleet was
listed as out of action but two-thirds
of the raf's 21 a400s were unserviceable
or unavailable
in just a matter of weeks these c-130s
as well as the rest of the fleet will no
longer be based here at Bryce Norton
instead they'll be up for sale to be
bought by other countries given they've
still got many more years worth of
flying in them an RAF Source said to me
scrapping the C-130 is probably one of
the worst military decisions the UK has
made in the post-world War era
responding to the sky news report the
defense secretary dismissed what he
described as tired arguments the l400i
performs the hurt on most tight it's got
a longer range bigger capacity you can
land in the same area in fact can land
in shorter distance the Hercules only
accounts for 10 of the fleet and the
overall Fleet for Lyft is now the
biggest it's been for 50 years
but selling the C-130 Fleet still
inevitably makes the UK's capability to
transport troops and rescue civilians
smaller debraham Sky News